لذي فضل فضلا
وان تولوا فاني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم كبير
الى الله مرجعكم وهو على كل شيء قدير
الا انهم يثنون صدورهم ليستخفوا منه الا
حين يستغشون ثيابه هم يعلم ما يسرون وما
يعلنون
انه عليم بذات الصدور
وما من دابه
في الارض الا على الله رزقها
ويعلم مستقرها
ومستودعها
كل في كتاب مبين
وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض في سته ايام
وكان عرشه على الماء
ليبلوكم ايكم احسن عملا
وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض في سته ايام
كان عرشه على الماء
ليبلوكم ايكم احسن عملا
ولئن قلت انكم مبعوثون من بعد الموت
ليقولن
الذين كفروا
الذين كفروا ان هذا الا سحر مبين
ولئن اخرنا
عنهم العذاب الى امه
معدوده ليقولن ما يحبسه
الا يوم ياتيهم ليس مصروفا عنهم
وضل عنهم ما كانوا يفترون
وحاق بهم ما كانوا به يستهزئون
ولئن ان اذقنا الانسان منا رحمه ثم
نزعناها منه انه ليؤوس كفور
ولئن اذقناه نعماء
بعد ضراء امسته ليقولن
ذهب السيئات عني
انه لفرح فخور
الا الذين صبروا وعملوا الصالحات اولئك
لهم مغفره
واجر كبير
فلعلك تارك بعض ما يوحى اليك وضائق
به صدرك ان يقولوا
ان يقولوا لولا انزل عليه كنز او جاء
معه ملك
انما انت نذير
والله على كل شيء
وكيل
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
حمدا كثيرا طيبا مبارك فيه من السماوات
ومن الارض ومن ما بينهما
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ام يقولون افتراه
قل فاتوا بعشر سور مثله مفت مفتريات
وادعوا من استطعتم من دون الله ان كنتم
صادقين
فان لم يستجيبوا لكم فاعلموا انما
انزل بعلم الله
فاعلموا انما انزل بعلم الله وان لا
اله الا هو فهل انتم
مسلمون
من كان يريد الحياه الدنيا وزينتها نوف
اليهم اعمالهم فيها
وهم فيها لا يبخسون
اولئك
الذين ليس لهم في الاخره الا النار
وحبط ما صنعوا وحبط ما صنعوا فيها وباطل
ما كانوا يعملون
افمن كان على بينه من ربه ويتلوه شاهد منه
ومن قبله كتاب موسى اماما ورحمه
اولئك
يؤمنون به ومن يكفر به من الاحزاب فالنار
موعده
فلا تك في مريه منه انه الحق من ربك
انه الحق من ربك ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون
ومن اظلم ممن من افترى على الله كذبا
اولئك
يعرضون على ربهم
ويقول الاشهاد هؤلاء
الذين كذبوا على ربهم
الا لعنه الله على الظالمين
الذين
يصدون عن سبيل الله ويبغونها عوجا
ويبغونها
عوجا وهم بالاخره هم كافرون
اولئك
لم يكونوا معجزين في الارض وما كان لهم من
دون الله من اولياء
يضاعف لهم العذاب
ما كانوا يستطيعون السمع وما كانوا يبصرون
اولئك
الذين خسروا انفسهم
وضل عنهم ما كانوا يفترون
لا جرم انهم في الاخره هم الاخسرون
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات واخبتوا
الى ربهم
اولئك
اصحاب الجنه هم فيها خالدون
مثل الفريقين كالاعمى والاصم والبصير
والسميع
هل يستويان
مثلا
افلا تذكرون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
اشهد اند
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
مالك
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين عليه
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر الله
المشكل
‏have anything just a little
announcement
feels nice when you do a little one
nothing I can't get you to do something
all right
tomorrow
you know it's nice when we tag team you
know
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
تنا ان شاء الله
‏are
first of
chapter
that are
chapter prophet
inح
صلى الله عليه
12 13
in temple here
and
not
said صلى الله عليه وسلم يا رسول الله
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
شيبتني هود واخواتها
sister
‏go with what
because chapter
they are theid
ofment
هود واخواتها
ان جامع الترمذي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
سوره
المرسلات
لقمان لقمانable
[Silence]
نوح
الحق
النبا
عما يتساءلون
نوقف
الانشقاق
انشقاق
سوره التكوير
نعم
اذا
وقعت الواقعه سوره الواقعه
سوره هود
سوره الواقعه
سوره المرسلات
سوره عمه يتساءلون
عن سوره اذا الشمس كورت
صلى الله عليه وسلم
واخواتها
‏take may
صلى الله عليه وسلم من صحيح الامام
‏areing
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا يصلين احدكم الا
واستعاذ من اربع او الا ويستعيذ من اربع
بمعنى
‏are
things
of the hell fire
the punishment of the grave
the fitna of this life and the next and
the thing is
المسيحجal
very important to look at the wording
we are seek
‏of eng chr as anist and prop
عليه
areجal
[Silence]
الكذب
الدجال
in
‏need
go back thous years
you find the asyon
car sales
today back they wouldell camel
‏kind
of su he's wearing his
and he selling camels and he's talking
up camels.
‏They don't get rust and they don't have
missing parts they don't have
transmissions.
But camels do get illnesses
and one of the illnesses that mostly
takes out the profit margin of a camel
just a car is something called.
الجبely
[Silence]
contag
as
‏to get a spot of a tye of fungus they
will take that away from all the other
all has to do is brush up and
this camel will infect all the others
and this is where the term comes fromج
or even moderns today they know this
word ajatory
term and that is someone who ‏is
ostzed. He he's a weirdo. He stays away
from people he contagious right from
that. So I see that my camel is starting
to get some jub on it. What do I do?
Well, I got to get rid of this guy
prant. We don't have an back then. So
what they do? They take tar
pitch
and they rub it in.
‏underir
and now look dirty
right as your car sales use car sales
same idea and so he is now rubbing this
all over where the spots of are and then
he sell it and by the time the buyer
figures out that this is actually
it's too lat you already sold ‏I don't
know what to tell you as is right
and so this act you might think what
does this have to do with
this act of covering up the fungus and
and covering up deceiving the spirit of
it is to make something look different
than what it really is this to beer
‏forth
why because willate another
so it looks is it is gold but
actually it's just gold plated it's not
actually gold it appears to be toally
gold ‏But is actually gold plated. They
refer to this as digit.
Then it later became a derogatory term.
Right? You call someone a daj. Someone
who's not just a liar but someone who
present evil in the form of good.
Someone who present
good in the form of bad. ‏Someone covers
up flaws mistakes, misgidances
and gives theusion that something is
pure something is good hypocr is called
and so the prop
said we are seek in four types and one
of them is ref in
‏to be a good man just a man and will to
be a propet and over time as people up
will
be mar and will nowit the asjجal
and will finally
الله رب العالمين
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
all the way to
seeking refug
فتنه المسيح الدجال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
المسيح الدجال انذره نوح
والنبيون من بعده من صحيح البخاري ابن عمر
نوح
عليه السلامجال
نوح المسيح الدجالحال
[Silence]
ان
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعيدنا من فتنه المحيا والممات
ومن عذاب جهنم ومن عذاب القبر ومن شر فتنه
المسيح الدجالنه
صلاه
تراويح والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
‏I only do
have take back
[Silence]
اللهم صل
السميع العظم
الله
[Silence]
فعلا في العشاء والنعم
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه اني لكم نذير
مبين
الا تعبدوا الا الله اني اخاف عليكم عذاب
يوم اليم
فقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه ما نراك
الا بشرا مثلنا
وما نراك اتبعك الا الذين هم اراذلنا بادي
الراك وما نرى لكم علينا من فضل بلظنكم
كاذبين
قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه من ربي
واتاني منه رحمه
واتاني رحمه من عنده فعميت
عليكم
انلزمكم وها وانتم لها كارهون
ويا قوم من ينصرني
من الله ويا قوم لا اسالكم عليه مالا ان
اجري الا على الله وما انا بطارد الذين
امنوا
انهم
ملاقوا ربهم ولكني
اراكم قوما من تجهلون
ويا قوم من ينصرني
من الله ان طردتهم
افلا تذكرون
ولا اقول لكم عندي خزائن الله ولا اعلم
الغيب ولا اقول اني ملك
ولا اقول للذين تزدري اعينكم
لن يؤتيهم الله خيرا
الله اعلم بما في انفسهم
اني
اذا لمن الظالمين
قالوا يا نوح قد جادلتنا فاكثرت جدالنا
فاتنا بما تعدنا ان كنت من الصادقين
قال انما ما ياتيكم به الله ان شاء
وما انتم بمعجزين
ولا ينفعكم
نصحي ان اردت ان انصح لكم
ان كان الله يريد ان يغويكم هو ربكم
هو ربكم واليه ترجعون
يقولون افت تراه
قل فان افتريته قل ان افتريت ام يقولون
افتراه
قل ان افتريته فعلي اجرامي وانا بريء
مما تجرمون
واوحي الى نوح انه لن يؤمن من قومك الا من
قد امن
فلا تبتئس بما كانوا يفعلون
واصنع الفلك باعيننا ووحينا
ولا تخاطبني في الذين ظلموا انهم
مغرقون
ويصنع الفلك وكلما مر عليه ملا من قومه
سخروا منه قال ان تسخروا منا فانا نسخر
منكم كما تسخرون
فسوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخزيه
ويحل عليه عذاب مقيم
حتى اذا جاء امرنا وثارت
النور قل نحمل فيها قل نحمل فيها من كل
زوجين اثنين واهلك الا
واهلك الا من سبق واهلك الا من فلما جاء
امرنا وثارت النور قلحمل فيها من كل زوجين
اثنين واهلك الا
من سبق عليه القول ومن امن وما امن معه
الا قليل
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وقال اركبوا فيها بسم الله مجريها ومرس
ساها ان ربي لغفور رحيم وهي تجري بهم في
موج كالجبال
ونادى نوح ابنه وكان في معزن
يا بني يا بني اركن معنا
يا بني اركن معنا ولا تكن مع الكافرين
قال ساوي الى جبل يعصمني من الماء
قال لا عاصم اليوم من امر الله الا من رحم
وحال بينهما الموج فكان من المغرقين
وقيل يا ارض ابلعي ماءك ويا سماء
اقلعيه
وغيض ماء وقضي الامر واستوت على الجود
وقيل بعدا للقوم الظالمين
ونادى نوح ربه فقال رب ان ابني من اهلي
وان وعدك الحق
وان وعدك الحق وانت احكم الحاكمين
قال يا نوح انه ليس من اهلك انه عمل غير
صالح
انه عمل غير صالح فلا تخاطبني في فلا
تجادل فلا تخاطبني بما ليس لك به علم
فلا تسالني ما ليس لك به علم اني اعذك ان
تكون من الجاهلين
قال رب اني اعوذ بك ان اسالك ما ليس لي به
علم والا تغفر لي وترحمني اكن من الخاسرين
قيل يا نوح اهبط بسلام منا وبركات
وبركات عليك وعلى امم ممن معك وهما
سنمتعهم ثم يمسهم منا عذاب اليم
تلك من انباء
الغيب نوحيها اليك ما كنت تعلمها
انت ولا قومك من قبل هذا فاصبر ان العاقبه
للمتقين
والى عاد اخاهم هودا
قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله
غيره ان انتم الا مفترون
يا قوم اسالكم عليه اجرا ان اجري الا على
الذي فطرني افلا تعقلون
ويا قوم استغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا اليه يرسل
السماء عليكم مدرارا ويزدكم قوه الى قوتكم
ولا تتولوا مجرمين
قالوا يا هود ما جئتنا ببينه
وما نحن بتاركي الهتنا عن قولك وما نحن لك
بمؤمنين
ان نقول الا اعتراك بعض الهتنا بسوء
قال اني
اشهد الله واشهدوا اني بريء مما تشركون من
دونه فكيدوني جميعا
ثم لا تنظرون
اني توكلت على الله ربي وربكم
ما دابه
الا هو اخذ بناصيتها
ان ربي على صراط مستقيم
فان تولوا فقد ابلغتكم
ارسلت به اليكم
ويستخلف ربي قوما غيركم ولا تضرونه
شيئا ان
ربي على كل شيء حفيظ
ولما جاء امرنا نجيناه هدى والذين امنوا
معه برحمه منا
ونجيناهم
من عذاب غليظ
وتلك عاد
وتلك عاد وتلك عاد جحدوا بايات ربهم
واتبعوا
واتبعوا امر كل جبار عنيد
وتلك
عاد جحدوا بايات ربهم وعصوا رسله واتبعوا
امر كل جبار عنيد
واتبعوا في هذه الدنيا لعنه
ويوم القيامه
الا ان عادا كفروا ربهم
الا بعدا لعاد
قوم هود
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
بسم
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
والى ثمود اخاهم صالحا
قال يا قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله
غيره هو انشاكم
من الارض واستعمركم
فيها فاستغفروه
ثم توبوا اليه
ان ربي قريب مجيب قالوا يا صالح قد كنت
فينا مرجو قبل هذا اتنهانا ان نعبد ما
يعبد اباؤنا
وانا لفي شك مما واننا لفي شك
واننا لفي شك مما تدعونا اليه مريب
واننا لفي شك مما تدعونا
اليه مريب قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على
بينه من ربي
واتاني واتاني منه رحمه فمن ينصرني من
الله ان عصيته فما تزيدونني
غير تخسير
ويا قوم هذه ايه الله لكم ايه ويا قوم هذه
ناقه الله لكم ايه فذروها تاكل في ارض
الله
ولا تمسوها بسوء
فياخذكم عذاب
قريب
فعق فعقروها فقال تمتعوا في داركم ثلاثه
ايام ذلك وعد غير مكذوب
فلما جاء امرنا نجينا صالحا
والذين امنوا معه برحمه مما
برحمه منا و ومن برحمه منا ومن عذاب ومن
خزي يومئذ
واخذ الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا فاصبحوا
في ديارهم جاثمين
كان لم يغنوا فيها
فلما جاء امرنا نجينا صالحا والذي الذين
امنوا معه برحمه منا ومن خزي يومئذ
ان ربك هو القوي العزيز
واخذ الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا في
ديارهم جاثمين
كان لم يغنوا فيها
الا ان ثمود كفروا ربهم
بعدا لثمود
ولقد جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى فقالوا
سلاما
ولقد جاءت
ولقد جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى قالوا
سلاما
قالوا سلاما فق قال سلام فما لبث
جاء
بعجل حنيذ
فلما راى ايديهم لا تصل اليه نكرهم نكرهم
واوجس منهم خيفه قالوا لا تخف انا ارسلنا
الى قوم لوط
وامراته قائمه
فضحكت
فبشرناها
باسحاق ومن وراء اسحاق يعقوب
قالت يا ويلتا
ااند عجوز وهذا بعني شيخا
ان هذا لشيء عجيب
قالوا اتعجبين من امر الله رحمه الله
وبركاته
عليكم اهل البيت
انه
حميد
مجيد
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
فلما
ذهب عن ابراهيم الروع وجاء جاءته البشرى
يجادلنا في قوم لوط ان ابراهيم لحليم
ارواه منب يا ابراهيم اعرض عن هذا انهم قد
جاء انهم قد جاء انه قد جاء امر ربك
وانهم اتيهم عذاب
غير مردود
فل ولما جاءت
رسلنا لوطا
سيء بهم سيء بهم وضاق بهم زرعا وقال هذا
يوم عصيب
وجاءه
قومه يهرعون اليه ومن قبل كانوا يعملون
سيئات
قال يا قوم هؤلاء
بناتي هن اطهر لكم فاتقوا الله ولا تخزوني
في ضيفي اليس منكم رجل رشيد
قالوا يا لوط لقد قالوا لقد علمت ما لنا
في بناتك من حق وانك لتعلم مريد
قال لو ان لي بكم قوه او او الى ركن شديد
قالوا يا لوط انا رسل ربك لن يصلوا اليك
فاسر باهلك بقطع من الليل ولا يلتفت منكم
احد الا امراتك
انه
مصيبه ما اصابهم
ان موعدهم الصبح اليس الصبح بقريب
فلما جاء امرنا جعلنا عاليها سافلها
جعلنا عاليها سافلها وامطرنا عليهم حجاره
وامطرنا عليهم حجاره
من سجيل
من منضود
[Arabic recitation]
وامطرنا عليها حجاره وامطرنا عليها حجاره
من سجيل منضود
مسومه عند ربك
مسومه عند ربك وما هي من الظالمين
ببعيد
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
المفروض
خلينا
[Silence]
خايف
اخدت الحل يا عم اه
وعلى فكره
لانه لما انا ببدا
البدايه
استووا اعتدلوا
استووا
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا قال يا قوم اعبدوا
الله ما
من اله غيره ولا تنقصوا المكيال والميزان
اني اركم بخير واني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم
محيط
ويا قوم اوفوا المكيال والميزان بالقسط
ولا تبخسوا الناس اشياءهم
ولا تعثوا في الارض مفسدين
بقيه الله خير لكم ان كنتم مؤمنين وما انا
عليكم بحفيظ
قالوا يا شعيب اصلاتك تامرك ان نترك ما
يعبد اباؤنا
او ان نفعل في اموالنا ما نشاء
انك لانت الحليم الرشيد
قال يا قوم ارايتم ان كنت على بينه من ربي
ورزقني منه رزقا حسنا وما اريد ان اخالفكم
الى ما انهاكم عنه ان اريد الا الاصلاح ما
استطعت وما توفيقي الا بالله عليه توكلت
واليه انيب
ويا قوم لا يجرمنكم شقاقي ان يصيبكم
مثل ما اصاب قوم نوح او قوم هود او قوم
صالح وما قوم لوط منكم ببعيد
واستغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا اليه ان ربي رحيم
ودود
قالوا يا شعيب ما نفقه كثيرا مما تقول
وانا
لنراك فينا ضعيفا
ولولا رهطك لرجمناك وما انت علينا بعزيز
قال يا قوم ارهطي اعز عليكم من الله
واتخذتموه وراءكم
ظهريا
ان ربي بما تعملون محيط ويا قوم اعملوا
على مكانتكم اني عامل
سوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب يخزيه ومن هو
كاذب وارتقبوا اني معكم رقيب
ولما جاء امرنا نجينا شعيبا والذين امنوا
معه برحمه منا
واخذت الذين ظلموا الصيحه فاصبحوا في
ديارهم جاثمين
كان لم يغنوا فيها الا بعدا لمدين كما
بعدت ثمود
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا وسلطان مبين
الى فرعون وملائه فاتبعوا امر فرعون وما
امر فرعون برشيد
يقدم قومه يوم القيامه فاوردهم النار وبئس
الورد المورود
واتبعوا في هذه لعنه ويوم القيامه بئس
الرفد المرفود
ذلك من انباء
القرى نقصه عليك منها قائم
وحصيد
وما ظلمهم وما ظلمنا ولكن ظلموا انفسهم
فما اغنت عنهم الهتهم التي يدعون من دون
الله من شيء لما جاء امر ربك وما زادوهم
غير تتبيب
وكذلك اخذ ربك اذا اخذ القرى وهي ظالمه ان
اخذه اليم شديد
ان في ذلك لايه لمن خاف عذاب الاخره
ذلك يوم مجموع له الناس وذلك يوم مشهود
وما نؤخره الا لاجل معدود
يوم ياتي لا تكلم نفس الا باذنه
يوم ياتي لا تكلم نفس الا باذنه فمنهم هم
شقي وسعيد
فاما الذين شقوا ففي النار لهم فيها زفير
وشهيق
خالدين فيها ما دامت السماوات والارض الا
ما شاء ربك ان ربك فعال لما يريد
واما الذين سعدوا ففي الجنه خالدين فيها
ما دامت السماوات والارض الا ما شاء ربك
عطاء
غير مجذوذ
فلا تك في مريه مما يعبد هؤلاء
ما يعبدون الا كما يعبد اباؤهم
من قبل وانا لموفوهم نصيبهم غير منقوص
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف فيه ولولا
كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي بينهم وانهم لفي شك
منه مريب
وان كلا لما ليوفينهم
ربك اعمالهم انه بما يعمل يعملون خبير
فاستقم كما امرت ومن تاب معك ولا تطغوا
انه بما تعملون بصير
ولا تركنوا الى الذين ظلموا فتمسكم
النار وما لكم من دون الله من اولياء
ثم لا تنصرون
واقم الصلاه طرفي النهار وزلفا من الليل
ان الحسنات يذهبن السيئات
ذلك ذكرى للذاكرين
واصبر فان الله لا يضيع اجر المحسنين
فلولا كان من القرون من قبلكم اولو بقيه
ينهون عن الفساد في الارض الا قليلا
ممن انجينا منهم واتبع الذين ظلموا ما
اترفوا فيه وكانوا مجرمين
وما كان ربك ليهلك القرى بظلم واهلها
مصلحون
ولو شاء ربك لجعل الناس امه واحده ولا
يزالون مختلفين
الا من رحم ربك ولذلك خلقهم وتمت كلمه ربك
لاملان
جهنم من الجنه والناس اجمعين
وكلا نقص عليك من انباء
الرسل ما نثبت به فؤادك وجاءك في هذه الحق
وموعظه وذكر ر للمؤمنين
وقل للذين لا يؤمنون اعملوا على مكانتكم
انا عاملون
وانتظروا
انا منتظرون
ولله غيب السماوات والارض واليه يرجع
الامر كله
واليه يرجع الامر كله فاعبده وت توكل عليه
وما ربك بغافل عما تعملون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
ر تلك ايات الكتاب المبين انا انزلناه
قرانا عربيا لعلكم تعقلون
نحن نقص عليك احسن القصص بما اوحينا اليك
هذا القران وان كنت من قبله لمن الغافلين
اذ قال يوسف لابيه يا ابت اني رايت احدد
عشر كوكبا والشمس والقمر رايتهم لي ساجدين
قال يا بني لا تقصص رؤياك على اخوتك
فيكيدوا لك كيدا ان الشيطان للانسان عدو
مبين
وكذلك يجتبيك ربك ويعلمك من تاويل
الاحاديث ويتم نعمته عليك
ويتم نعمته عليك وعلى ال يعقوب كما اتمها
على ابويك من قبل ابراهيم واسحاق
ان ربك عليم حكيم
لقد كان في يوسف واخوته ايات للسائلين
اذ قالوا ليوسف واخوه احب الى ابينا منا
ونحن عصبه ان ابانا لفي ضلال مبين
اقتلوا يوسف او اطرحوه ارضا يخل لكم وجه
ابيكم وتكونوا من بعده قوما صالحين
قال قائل
منهم لا تقتلوا يوسف والقوه في غيابه الجب
يلتقطه بعض السياره ان كنتم فاعلين
قالوا يا ابانا ما لك لا تامنا على يوسف
وانا له لناصحون
ارسله معنا غدا
يمتع ويلعب وانا له لحافظون
قال اني ليحزنني ان تذهبوا به واخاف ان
ياكله الذئب وانتم عنه غافلون
قالوا لئن اكله الذئب ونحن عصبه انا اذا
لخاسرون
فلما ذهبوا به واجمعوا على ان يجعلوه في
غيابه
الجب واوحينا
فلما ذهبوا به واجمعوا ان يجعلوه في غيابه
الجب واوحينا اليه لتنبئهم
بامرهم هذا وهم لا يشعرون
وجاءوا اباهم عشاء
يبكون
قالوا يا ابانا انا ذهبنا نستبق وتركنا
يوسف عند متاعنا فاكله الذئب وما انت
بمؤمن لنا ولو كنا صادقين
وجاؤوا على قميصه بدم كذب قال بل سولت لكم
انفسكم امرا فصبر جميل والله المستعان على
ما تصفون
وجاء جاءت سياره فارسلوا واردهم فادلى
دلوه قال يا بشرى هذا غلام واسروه بضاعه
والله عليم بما يعملون
وشروه بثمن بخس دراهم معدوده وكانوا فيه
من الزاهدين
وقال الذي اشتراه من مصر لامراته اكرمي
مثواه عسى ان ينفعنا او نتخذه ولدا
وكذلك مكنا ليوسف في الارض ولنعلمه من
تاويل الاحاديث
والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون
ولما بلغ اشده اتيناه حكما وعلما
وكذلك نجزي المحسنين
وراودته التي هو في بيتها عن نفسه وغلقت
الابواب وقالت هيت لك قال معاذ الله انه
ربي احسن مثواي
انه لا يفلح الظالمون
ولقد همت به وهم بها لولا برهان ربه كذلك
لنصرف عنه السوء والفحشاء
انه من عبادنا المخلصين
واستبق الباب وقدت قميصه من دبر والف يا
سيدها لدى الباب
قالت ما جزاء من اراد باهلك سوءا الا ان
يسجن او عذاب
اليم قال هي راودتني عن نفسي
وشهد شاهد من اهلها ان كان قميصه قد من
قبل فصدقت وهو من الكاذبين
وان كان قميصه قد من دبر فكذبت وهو من
الصادقين
فلما راى قميصه قد من دبر قال انه من
كيدكن
ان كيدكن
عظيم
يوسف اعرض عن هذا واستغفري لذنبك انك كنت
من الخاطئين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
وقال نسوه في المدينه امراه العزيز تراود
فتاها عن نفسه قد شغفها حبا انا لنراها في
ضلال مبين فلما سمعت بمكرهن ارسلت اليهن
واعتدت لهن متكا واتت كل واحده منهن سكينا
واتت كل واحده منهن سكينا وقالت اخرج
عليهن
فلما ما راينه واكبرنه وقطعن ايديهن وقلن
حاش لله ما هذا بشرا وقلنا وقل محاش لله
ما هذا بشرا ان هذا الا ملك كريم
قالت فذلكن الذي لمتنني فيه ولقد راودته
عن نفسه فاستعصم ولئن لم يفعل ما امره
ليسجنن وليكونن من الصاغرين
قال ربي السجن احب الي مما يدعونني اليه
وان تصرف عني كيدهن اصب اليهن واكن من
الجاهلين
فاستجاب له ربه فصرف عنه كيدهن انه هو
السميع العليم
ثم بد لهم من بعد ما راوا الايات ليسجننه
حتى حين
ودخل معه السجن فتيان
قال احدهما اني اراني اعصر خمرا وقال
الاخر اني اراني احمل فوق راسي خبزا تاكل
الطير منه
نبئنا بتاويله انا نراك من المحسنين
قال لا ياتيكما طعام ترزقانه الا نباتكما
بتاويله قبل ان ياتيكما
ذلكما مما علمني ربي اني تركت مله قوم لا
يؤمنون بالله وهم بالاخره هم كافرون
واتبعت مله ابائي
ابراهيم واسحاق ويعقوب
ما كان لنا ان نشرك بالله من شيء
ذلك من فضل الله علينا وعلى الناس ولكن
اكثر الناس لا يشكرون
يا صاحبي السجن ارباب متفرقون خير ام الله
الواحد القهار
ما تعبدون من دونه الا اسماء
سميتموها
انتم واباؤكم
ما انزل الله بها من سلطان
ان الحكم الا لله
امر الا تعبدوا الا اياه
ذلك الدين القيم ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون
يا صاحبي السجن اما احدكما فيسقي ربه خمرا
واما الاخر فيصلب فتاكل الطير من راسه قضي
الامر الذي فيه تستفتيان
وقال للذي ظن انه ناج منهما اذكرني عند
ربك فانساه الشيطان الشيطان ذكر ربه فلبث
في السجن بضع سنين
وقال الملك اني ارى سبع بقرات سمان ياكلهن
سبع عجاف وسبع سنبلات خضر واخر يابسات
يا ايها الملا افتوني في رؤياي ان كنتم
للرؤيا تعبرون
قالوا اضغاث احل
وما نحن بتاويل الاحلام بعالمين
وقال الذي نجى منهما واذكر بعد امه انا
انبئكم بتاويله فارسلون
يوسف ايها الصديق افتنا في سبع بقرات سمان
ياكلهن سبع عجاف وسبع سنبلات خضر ضر واخر
يابسات
لعلي ارجع الى الناس لعلهم يعلمون
قال تزرعون سبع سنين
فما حصدتم فذروه في سنبله الا قليلا مما
تاكلون
ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك سبع شداد ياكلن ما
قدمتم لهن
الا قليلا مما تحسنون
ثم ياتي من بعد ذلك عام فيه يغاث الناس
وفيه يعصرون
وقال الملك ائتوني به فلما جاءه الرسول
قال ارجع الى ربك فاسالهما بال النسوه
التي قطعن ايديهن
ان ربي بكيدهن عليم
قال ما خطبكن اذ راودتن يوسف عن نفسه قل
حاش لله ما علمنا عليه من سوء
قالت امراه العزيز الان حصحص الحق انا
راودته عن نفسه وانه لمن الصادقين
ذلك ليعلم اني لم اخنه بالغيب
وان الله لا يهدي كيد الخائنين
وما ابرئ نفسي ان النفس لاماره
بالسوء الا ما رحم ربي
ان ربي غفور رحيم
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ان شاء الله
الشفع والوتر
الله
اكبر اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والعصر ان الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ويل لكل همزه لمزا
الذي جمع مالا
وعددا
يحسب ان ماله اخلده كلا لينبذن
في حطما
ادراكما الحطمه
نار الله الموقده
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم مؤصده
في عمد ممدده
الله اكبر سبحان الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الصلاه والسلام عليك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله الصين اشهد ان لا
اله الا
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر بسم
رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله اكبر
سامع سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
الله
اكبر
[Arabic recitation]
على ال محمد كما صليت
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس